and Lily's doing something illegal she
had to say yes to this I might say yes
to more experiences but we'll see hey
everyone welcome to another episode of
unlocking lily if I believe that this
world would be a better place if we all
just embrace who we truly are Evan is
currently an investor in my business and
he's mentoring me to help me build my
coaching and speaking practice and it's
such an honor to invite all of you guys
to join me on my startup journey as an
entrepreneur you will go through tough
times whether if it's in your personal
life or your business life so I was
going through a dip in my life and when
that happens I rely heavily on people
who care about me so I was speaking to
my best friend a couple of weeks ago and
out of nowhere she just said why don't
you just come to Mexico to visit me and
out of nowhere I just said yes without
even thinking about it and that's
unusual for me because usually I would
make up some kind of excuse why I can't
go but something came over me and I just
said yes and I realized that I've been
saying no to too many things I've been
saying no to opportunities no to new
experiences so I decided that while I'm
in Mexico I'm gonna spend the entire
week saying yes I don't know what's
going to happen during the trip because
I'm gonna be saying yes to everything um
but I'm hoping that I'm gonna learn a
lesson from this I don't know I I don't
know what's gonna come out of it but it
feels good it feels good to say yes and
it all started from my best friend
asking me to come to Mexico and the
amazing thing is guys I'm gonna bring
all of you with me as I spend my entire
week in Mexico saying yes
I got to the airport so my week of
seeing yes begins right now
I was randomly selected and they asked
me if I wanted to go into the party yes
look they had to do screen my laptop but
anyway always well because I ended up
skipping the line so that was really
good so so far that that's yes number
one okay
I'm also a good start we'll see
[Music]
and finally here I wasn't able to film
before I passed customs bypass customs
and it's kind of quiet it's looking
sunny outside I'm going to go find my
friend my phone is about to die so
hopefully I'll be able to record some
fun stuff before it dies but if not I
will charge it up and at her place and
then show you guys around so I'm here
with my friends say hello what's your
name
Amir there's Olivia so apparently olivia
has plans for me where are we going
so I'm nicely settled in my friends
place and everyone just left so I'm
gonna get back to work
[Music]
all right so I finished doing some work
at home and now I'm going out for a
night out of town with the girls my yes
counter is looking kind of sad I think I
need to say yes to more things we're
gonna go to this hip restaurant and
we'll see it's been very tame very very
tame not not much going on with a yes
maybe I should start a guest counter
underneath super dark alright guys see
you guys in the restaurant
it's like that yes tis especially but
I'm sure it's something
Hey hi I'm Bruce Wayne you should come
too through here yes and you're at the
right place to say yes oh every good
morning guys today is the first full day
in Mexico we are going to Tulum we're
going to go to the beach and I think
there's some fun surprises I'm gonna be
saying yes to the beach I'm gonna say
yes to playing on the beach
look over there so hey we could play
frisbee yes they were finally on the
road and off to the beach
[Music]
Seve is my is my co-star spent about 45
minutes to an hour on the beach there's
only so much of Beach I can do I'm going
to explore Tulum and look at the local
vendors and the local businesses and see
if I could do some shopping and maybe
bring back some souvenirs for my friends
I just taking a moment to take a rest
before I go back and do some work at the
restaurant there it's so beautiful here
every single store is carefully crafted
a so much attention to
detail it's a really a beautiful place
lots of creativity and beauty all around
it's nice I'm gonna head back and do
some work answer some emails try to find
some reliable Wi-Fi which is hard to
come across these days so it's about
evening time we're going to a restaurant
but apparently we have to follow a path
and the kids are calling The Secret
Garden Way see it's all a new experience
for me right now
[Music]
along our discover we found the
gratitude tent
apparently so what do we do here do we
do we do we say what we're grateful for
is that what it is Ahmir what are you
grateful for today
right behind me there you go the other
ones running away nice
gravity is very important
we finally made it to the restaurant
Paul you kinda it's on the beach and I
don't know what I'm gonna eat I think we
ordered something interesting for me we
shall see okay so I just got back to my
friend's place after spending time in
the beach I couldn't actually record the
nighttime stuff because it was just so
grainy it's pitch-black everywhere but
it's a second day of my trip and second
day of my week of saying yes and so far
the one that really stood out to me by
saying yes as saying yes to playing with
the kids I think there's so much that we
can learn from children that they are so
present and I was forced to be present
and that's something that I try to do
but I feel like I need to do more as far
as like the food stuff is concerned it's
okay you know I'm not too concerned
about that but really seeing yes to
playing for the kids is the one that's
like right up there for me
I still have another five days to go and
we'll see where it takes me so far so
good so today I said yes to doing a
Reiki appointment I have never done
anything like this before but it comes
with rave reviews so I'm going to try
this out and let you guys know how this
goes
I just finished an amazing session with
my new friend today Mari
mega bunny hmm yeah she she brought up a
lot of things in me she said I'm highly
analytical which is true I don't connect
with my heart enough money what what is
some what do you love about doing this
type of work you know that um this is
energy treatment more than physical
therapy so because if if your energy is
not good you know and you're physically
you are not good but if I just treat
your physical level you you cannot
remove the real reason that you have its
energy level so I try to you know detox
the negative and the heavy energy
instead of you to treat you and so if
the energy level it's good you are
physically and mentally you're gonna be
good so this is what I do and I love it
thank you thank you so much and I'll put
a link for your website given Ireland so
you guys could give her some love as
well
hey everyone so today is day 3 of my
week of saying gas so far it's been okay
I've been saying yes to a lot of
different kinds of food and I think the
night before I talked about the one
thing that I feel really good about
saying yes to is playing with the kids I
think in this midpoint of my journey
it's important to note something saying
yes to random things that don't really
align with your values is not
necessarily the best thing because I
knew myself really well
and I know what it is that is good for
me it's a saying yes to certain types of
food or certain type their drinks may
not really align
my healthy way of living however seeing
yes to things that are meaningful like
seeing yes to children and playing with
them and really being present for them
and those moments is so hard to get back
so that's why I've learned if you
wouldn't say yes to something see yes to
things that I do you feel like you put
off but you know it's gonna bring you
the utmost fulfillment and saying yes to
random things that don't really align
with your values is probably not the
best way to go today is a very half work
half vacation kind of day I'm going to
be meeting with Evan today I'm going to
be doing some coaching calls and some
work so even while on vacation you know
I don't like losing momentum at all I
like to keep it going so it's a work
life type vacation for me I am going
into town and we're going to explore
some fun local arts and crafts just want
to show you guys this crazy crazies
couch wondering if I should get it for
my house it's a giant
dragon couch so we're in Mexico yes we
are and Lilly's doing something illegal
she's like I had to say yes I had to say
yes to this she hijacked the UH the
camera so let me over here thinks I
should buy this what do you think this
could be great for your clubbing notes
for my clubbing of it because that's
what I do I go I go clubbing all the
time maybe I should get it I'll say yes
do it I'll pull it off what do you guys
think leave in the comments below what
do you think yes okay fine I'll say yes
[Music]
apparently I had to try out this ice
cream
in town look at they put in extra effort
and everything that they do I'll show
you how the ice cream looks like looks
like on the flowers now that gelato
what definitely looked better than it
tasted but you know what I'm glad I went
everyone told me that I had to go and
that's the thing you know you do
something that is memorable because you
could buy gelato anywhere and they're
just like pile it on but they put in so
much effort actually make a flower out
of it it's an important lesson learned
you know always over deliver in value
hey everyone so today is day four of my
week of saying yes in Mexico today I'm
primarily doing a lot of work so every
single Tuesday I do different live
events with different youtubers and we
speak about entrepreneurship and
personal development and later on
tonight I'll be doing my school of life
coaching as well so it's a lot of work
and at the same time I get to look at
this beautiful scenery and that's a
thing you know it may seem to you guys
that I'm working a lot while I'm on
vacation and at the same time I really
love what I do and I hate I hate losing
momentum so that's why that's why I
continue to do it and I don't like
breaks in between I'm trying to find the
balance between having some fun spending
time with my friend and her kids and her
family and doing work at the same time
and I think I done a pretty good job so
tomorrow's gonna be a little bit more
fun and today is work and fun at the
same time
[Music]
so I've completed all my live hangouts
and I'm sitting down right now and about
to start my school of life course so
this started last week where I work with
nine people for nine weeks and I cover
three important topics number one is
self-awareness knowing what you stand
for and knowing the things that drain
you knowing the things that bring you
life and creating an environment that is
really supportive of you stemming from
self-awareness
the second thing is clearing out any
limiting beliefs and just replacing all
those negative thoughts with positive
patterns and the last part is the
contribution peace is knowing what it is
that you want to contribute out in this
world what I find really unique about
this course in comparison to any of the
other course I have done is that it's
completely live and there's a huge
accountability piece that is throughout
the entire course I realized a while ago
is that most online courses has a 96%
dropout rate which is huge and this is
something that I don't want for the
courses that I do because the reality is
the reason why I want to do this is
because I want people to make a change
in their life I want to make sure that
people come out transformed and that
cannot be done if 96% of my students are
dropping out so I made the commitment to
spend this nine weeks
intensely working with every single
person in the group through the live
group coaching as well as doing the
accountability and we have done one week
and so far it's been amazing the people
in the community there are so supportive
of each other and that's exactly what I
wanted out of this course so it's the
second week right now and let's see how
everything unfolds but I feel like it's
going to be an amazing amazing journey
it is 11:03 p.m.
and I'm about to jump on Coach's Corner
usually I do these episodes in the
morning on my youtube channel but today
it's just been such a full day running
around but I've made the commitment to
do daily content on my youtube channel
so here it goes
I'm gonna go live right now all right
everyone I am extremely exhausted but
feeling so grateful and so happy for the
day of had on Tuesdays I have a very
full day it starts off with my YouTube
live hangouts and then it ends with my
school of life course so I'm gonna go to
bed
and tomorrow I have an exciting day
because I will be taking some pictures
with a photographer friend of mine here
in Mexico so I will see you guys
tomorrow morning good night we're off to
see Vincent for my photo shoot last
little while my social media presence
has been kind of you know kind of weak
this is a mirror Hector I'm thinking of
doing an upgrade of of all the images
that I have I only have one picture that
I post all the time I met Vincent about
ten years ago or eight years ago no
eight years ago at these lovely people's
wedding and what I really loved about
him is that he's one of the most
inspired people I've ever met everything
that he sees he sees through beauty and
awe so yeah and that's what you want in
a photographer anyway you want
photographers who could actually capture
the beauty in people and the things
around you so we're here Vincent's place
and my friend has told me that he is the
number one wedding photographer in
Mexico and he's rated one of the top 10
with wedding photographers in the world
just kind of cool right here we have
some ladies doing a yoga outside which
looks beautiful as I wait for him he's
held up at the bank see
[Music]
so I'm here with Vincent and as we were
talking about my photoshoot we kind of
started sharing different messages about
entrepreneurship and Vincent has a
really good message so what do you have
to say to all the entrepreneurs out
there
well well familiar I think I tried to
make it as simple as possible but I
really for me to really add value to the
society and to really be happy you just
have to find something that you love and
then have great ethics the know just be
good to your word and work through your
heart and connect as blessed as you can
with every person because no yeah money
is great money can come and go the most
important thing is the value in the
connection that you have with your
clients because that that real
connection is is and how much love you
feel and you'll give and you'll get back
whilst you whilst you work and that's
ultimately what keeping makes you happy
and then people see that and then when
you provide that value that they want
more of it and you just have you end up
with wonderful relationships that all
thrive and and yet if you stay on that
path connecting doing something that you
enjoy you love and you provide a real
valued experience then people will then
you'll be happy and everyone else that
around you will be happy too it's really
not that complicated
it's more about what you do well if
you're asked and money what does money
will he bring you you know if you don't
know how to handle it you could lose it
then you have fear of loss and and yes
not really consistent then money comes I
think once you provider
great service to society and a heartfelt
experience yeah for me that's what I've
always tried to do and and I think
that's how you create a variable society
different people really connect and and
you know business is all about fair
exchange so if you could provide a
service you get a fair monetary exchange
back and yeah we don't want to be in the
in the business of ripping people off or
anything like that you know and I see
it's far too much in the world today lot
of people doing things that they're not
really happy doing they don't really
like but they don't really know what
they like either so they kind of be a
bit lost and yeah and so you're the best
way to do something that you connect
with that you enjoy doing work at that
as hard as you can and keep on you keep
on creating being as creative as you can
with that connect with people around you
that also do that task will do that
hobby or whatever and then keep on
working hard at it and then people
you'll end up becoming very good at it
and then people pay you for that because
yeah because you do it well and that's
what people way yeah it's true we are
done the photo shoot so we're gonna go
off to breakfast apparently there's this
place called ladder Lucca which everyone
talks about so that's where we're gonna
go
so tonight is my last night here in
Mexico so I'm just waiting for my best
friend to come she's putting the kids to
bed and we're gonna go in
town and have some fun have some food go
do some shopping so I decided to stop
the week of saying yes midweek because I
just didn't see the point of it I think
when you have a lot of self-awareness to
know what it is that really pushes you
forward and what it is that you really
enjoy there's really no point in saying
yes to random things that you don't feel
like it's aligned with your values so
here I was offered a lot of things that
I probably cannot even mention in front
of you guys on camera that I just didn't
feel like was aligned with my value so I
decided to say no to all of those things
and what I did say yes to was a lot of
wonderful experiences saying yes to
getting to know people who are like
hearted people who are creatives people
who are entrepreneurs this afternoon I
had the amazing opportunity in doing
some photos with a friend that I met
approximately 10 years ago and just
sitting down with him and asking him
about his journey and what is the advice
that he has for entrepreneurs and
there's just so much passion inside of
him and and that's what I wanted to say
yes to really connecting with people and
being present for them and not saying
yes to random experiences that could
potentially put me in danger
so this is my last night we're gonna go
out you never know we still have the
night is still young things might happen
I might say yes to more experiences but
we'll see
[Music]
so right here I'm in Playa del Carmen
and I'm in the main street it's called v
and it's a hundred percent pedestrian
people walk around it looks pretty
lively right now and coffee shops here
lots of shopping lots of tourists we're
gonna lower a little bit I'm giving some
shopping look I love being found what is
that you got there
be extraordinary do you think I should
buy it I think so I think I should buy
it I have to say yes to him III say yes
to being extraordinary that's true
[Music]
hey everyone so I am back home after
spending the night out with my best
friend Olivia in Playa del Carmen we
went shopping we bought lots of food I
am full and hard but very content and
look what I found
I found a sweatshirt that says be
extraordinary because extraordinary is
my one word because I believe that every
single human being is capable of
extraordinary things
so speaking of extraordinary I'm gonna
jump on Coach's Corner right now I know
it's so late it's like midnight right
now but I made the commitment to put out
daily content every single day on my
youtube channel where I hop on and I
share an amazing tip or suggestion to
help people become even more
extraordinary so right now I'm gonna hop
on I'm going to talk about how to
command respect yeah anyways guys
tomorrow is my day to fly back to
Toronto I'm so excited to go back home
as fun as this has been I'm missing home
so I'm gonna go back
and I'm looking forward to that have an
amazing night and I will see you guys
tomorrow morning alright everyone so I'm
on my way to the airport to go back home
to Toronto and as I'm driving I'm kind
of looking back to this entire week and
what has happened I think originally I
had all of these ideas in my head how
the week would go I was I thought that I
would do some crazy things and I would
say yes do a whole lot of things that
scare me
but the reality is it didn't happen
because those opportunities actually
didn't come by because I spent the
entire week spending time with people
who I really cared about people like my
best friend and her kids her husband
spending time with you guys spending
time on YouTube spending time answering
your comments spending time Lewis my
lovely people from the school of life my
coaching clients and really taking care
of that and I said yes to opportunities
one thing that I said yes to that I'm
really really grateful for is is a Reiki
healer I've never really done any Reiki
healing before and she was so
interesting that she she was so
intuitive in what I was feeling I felt
like there was so much energy inside of
me that I wanted to put out in the world
but I'm highly analytical so I have a
tendency of overthinking things
and it's interesting how she picked up
on that because that's something that
I've been trying to do for the last
couple of months because I have the
self-awareness to actually know that
this is something that that's challenges
me a little bit
the second thing that I was really
grateful for that I said yes to is doing
an impromptu photo shoot with a good
friend Vincent I met him about 10 years
ago and I've always had him in the back
of my mind that if I ever wanted to take
pictures I would definitely go with him
and not only because he's an incredibly
talented photographer and he's one of
the highest rated photographers in the
world is the fact that he has this
beautiful energy about him and this
personality just sparkles and I couldn't
pinpoint what that was and I came to the
realization is that he based his entire
company's entire business around giving
back giving back to people and really
going from a place of connection so he
takes pictures and as I was talking to
him I felt there was so much empathy and
connection when he was taking the images
and I think that's something that you
can't bottle that's something that you
can't learn from books it's something
that you just don't feel and that's what
makes him so incredibly magical and the
third thing is probably the most
important one is spending time with my
best friend and her family I think in
life we have all have a tendency of
making excuses and not spending time
with the people that we truly care about
it's been almost a year since she left
Toronto and we've been trying to
schedule in time to see each other and
we've seen each other here and there but
we haven't really gotten the time to sit
and chat
so took a couple of nights I was able to
really sit with her and have
conversations with her and really kind
of get her caught up in what's going on
with my life which was really nice and
those two little boys that really truly
have stolen my heart they are the
sweetest kindest most giving little boys
I've ever met in my entire life and I'm
really looking forward to them coming
back to Toronto they are coming back to
visit us in two months so yeah so those
are the things that I learned during
this trip and it wasn't so much about
doing wild crazy things as it was really
connecting with human beings who were
aligned with my values and what I
believe in and really taking the time to
have conversations with them and the
question of the day is who are the
people in your life that you want to
spend more time with write in the
comments below and I'll join in on the
discussion and I have a special shout
out for Jordan Mitchell Phil it's key
thank you so much for writing that
awesome comment in my last video and
that is right let's make this world
extraordinary and look at my t-shirt
right here be extraordinary perfect fit
to this shout out and guys thank you so
much for watching and more importantly
being on this journey with me it's been
over 10 months and I feel like I'm
growing changing and going on this wild
journey look at this as I'm talking
about a journey I'm going on my journey
and going to the airport and sometimes
you know I feel like it can be lonely
when you are on the journey of personal
development and growing your business
but it gives you the comfort and knowing
that you guys are all there with me so
thank you so much again and I will see
you guys there
very soon by Bellini people would see
diamonds what would the small community
have the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details